[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen Samstagabend
wünsche ich Ihnen was im Sport passiert
ist das erfahren Sie von Norbert König
zum Beispiel Skispringen in Planitzer
und die Situation in der Ukraine war
auch Hauptthema beim Kurzbesuch gestern
von Bundeskanzler Scholz bei
US-Präsident beiden zum Auftakt des
Treffens beurteten sie dann wolle bei
der Unterstützung der Ukraine weiter eng
zusammenarbeiten etwa bei der Frage der
Waffenlieferungen beiden sagte der
Bundeskanzler habe schwierige
Entscheidungen in Deutschland
vorangetrieben wie höre
Verteidigungsausgaben und die Abkehr von
russischem Gas
der Rüstungskonzern rein Metall
verhandelt über den Bau einer
Panzerfabrik in der Ukraine diese könne
jährlich bis zu 400 Kampfpanzer vom Typ
Panther produzieren sagt Unternehmen
Chef paper er hoffe auf eine
Entscheidung in den nächsten zwei
Monaten das Werk könne gegen russische
Luftangriffe geschützt werden
russlandsexpräsident mit WDF drohte mit
Angriff auf die Fabrik sollte sie
tatsächlich gebaut werden
noch Vorwürfen über die Verschleppung
ukrainischer Kinder hat die Organisation
SOS-Kinderdorf ihren russischen
Mitgliedsverein suspendiert und alle
Zahlungen dorthin gestoppt vergangene
Woche hatte das ZDF-Magazin frontal
aufgedeckt dass SOS-Kinderdorf Russland
die Zwangsumsiedlung ukrainischer Kinder
verwickelt ist einen interne
Untersuchung der Hilfsorganisation
erbrachte das Werte und Richtlinien der
SOS-Kinderdörfer massiv verletzt wurden
der russische Verein habe Fördergelder
der russischen Regierung beantragt und
pro russische Propaganda verbreitet
morgen trifft sich das Kabinett für zwei
Tage zur Klausur auf Schloss Meseberg
die Liste der Streit Themen ist lang so
liegen sich SPD und Grüne zum Beispiel
mit der FDP wegen der
Kindergrundsicherung in den Haaren sie
ist im Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart soll
ab 2025 kommen und alle bisherigen
Leistungen für familienbündeln
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner von der FDP
hält es für falsch nur auf Geldzahlungen
zu setzen über den konflikt-
ein Fünftel aller in Deutschland
lebenden Minderjährigen sind von Armut
betroffen darüber sind sich
Kinderschutzorganisationen staatliche
Stellen und das Statistische Bundesamt
einig arme Kinder obwohl ihre Eltern
arbeiten
etwa zwei Drittel aller Kinder die in
Armut leben leben bei Erwerbstätigen die
aber ein prekäres Einkommen haben das
nicht ausreicht um ihre ganze Familie zu
versorgen jedes Kind in Armut ist eines
zu viel deshalb hat die grüne
Familienministerin ein Gesetz erarbeitet
ab 2025 soll die Kinder Grundsicherung
alle Leistungen also Kindergeld
Bürgergeld und kinderzuschläge für
einkommensschwache bündeln 12 Milliarden
Euro soll das Ganze kosten doch jetzt
gibt's Streit ums Geld die FDP und ihr
Finanzminister blockieren es geht darum
dass die Reihenfolge die falsche ist wir
müssen erstmal besprechen was wollen wir
eigentlich machen bevor wir seriös
überhaupt einen Preis benennen können
ich kenne bisher keine inhaltliche
Begründung für die 12 Milliarden per
Zeitungs Interview lässt die
Familienministerin wissen die
Kindergrundsicherung ist das wichtigste
sozialpolitische Vorhaben dieser
Regierung daran wird sich die Koalition
messen lassen müssen
auch für die SPD ist die
Kindergrundsicherung ein muss nicht
verhandelbar man hofft auf ein Einlenken
der FDP für uns ist es wichtig dass in
der Koalition einigkeit herrscht über
diese über diese Projekte es geht um die
Modernisierung des Landes es geht um den
sozialen Zusammenhalt in Deutschland die
Kinder Grundsicherung ab morgen
sicherlich Thema bei der Klausurtagung
der Bundesregierung hier auf Schloss
Meseberg
und jetzt zu einem Problem das für die
Verantwortlichen vor Ort immer schwerer
zu handhaben ist
illegale Einreise nach Deutschland
folgende Zahlen lassen die Dringlichkeit
an vergangenes Jahr stellten rund
218.000 Menschen Erstanträge auf Asyl im
gleichen Zeitraum registrierte die
Bundespolizei fast 92.000 unerlaubte
einreisen anders gesagt viele der
antragstellenden sind vorher illegal
über die Grenze gekommen häufig nach
Süddeutschland und in den letzten Jahren
sind es deutlich mehr geworden Claudia
Vogelmann berichtet
wer den Grenzübergang Walserberg von
Österreich nach Bayern mit einem
Fahrzeugkennzeichen eines Drittstaates
passiert wird angehalten und
kontrolliert
1.400 Schleuse gingen in der
Bundespolizei im vergangenen Jahr
alleine an den Grenzübergänge nach
Bayern ins Netz 30.000 Menschen aus
Afghanistan Syrien dem Iran und der
Türkei versuchten in diesem Zeitraum
über Bayern nach Deutschland zu gelangen
das waren 86% mehr als im Jahr zuvor die
deutsch-österreichische Grenze ist nach
wie vor ein Brennpunkt mit Blick auf die
Gale Migration in der Oberpfalz bei
Regensburg dient bereits ein Hotelschiff
auf der Donau als Unterkunft für
Menschen aus dem Iran und aus Syrien der
Landkreis Regensburg ist mit der
Unterbringung am Limit 3000 Asylsuchende
und 2000 Menschen aus der Ukraine halten
sich derzeit in dieser Region auf die
Landrätin fordert Unterstützung
das Hauptthema ist natürlich das
innerhalb der EU mit den Mitgliedstaaten
zu koordinieren und das nächste ist
natürlich außerhalb der EU zu
koordinieren wie können
rückführungsmöglichkeiten sein wie kann
auch AG gezielte Arbeitsmigration
funktionieren aber wir müssen als EU
auch auf unsere Rechtsstaatlichkeit
achten und auch die EU-Außengrenzen
sicher eigentlich kann man diese
EU-Grenze zwischen Österreich und
Deutschland ohne Kontrollen passieren
doch wegen der hohen Zahl illegal
einreisender erhält die Bundespolizei
den Auftrag hier zu kontrollieren ein
Auftrag der regelmäßig verlängert wird
die Rentenbeiträge bleiben stabiler als
bisher angenommen das erwartet
Arbeitsminister Heil der Beitragssatz
müsse auch nach Auslaufen der bis 2025
geltenden Obergrenze nur moderat
angehoben werden sagte Heil dem
redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland
hintergrund ist die gute Lager am
Arbeitsmarkt derzeit gäbe ist 5
Millionen sozialversicherungspflichtige
Beschäftigte mehr als vor zehn Jahren
vorhergesagt
auch knapp ein Monat nach den schweren
Erdbeben in der Türkei und in Syrien
lässt sich das Leid der Betroffenen
Menschen kaum ermessen von mehr als
50.000 Toten ist die Rede und fast 40
Milliarden Euro entschieden
unter denen im türkischen Erdbebengebiet
irgendwie weiterleben müssen sind auch
4,6 Millionen Kinder in nur da hat
unsere Kollegin Isabel Thymian
beobachtet wie sie das Grauen
verarbeiten und wie ihnen dabei geholfen
wird
die zwölfjährige essmanode wird die
Nacht vom 6 auf den 7 Februar wohl nie
vergessen das Haus ihrer Familie in
nurda wurde durch das Erdbeben völlig
zerstört
seitdem lebt sie in einer Zeltstadt mit
ihren Eltern und den drei Geschwistern
und hilft der Mutter wo sie nur kann
tagsüber kann sie sich ablenken doch
nachts kommt die Angst
wache ich auf und kann zur Schule gehen
im Camp aber wenn es dunkel wird fürchte
ich mich und kann nicht schlafen
um die Kinder etwas abzulenken hat
UNICEF in nurda ein Spielzelt aufgebaut
singen gegen die Angst
viele drücken das Trauma dass sie erlebt
haben sehr unterschiedlich aus manche
sind apathisch oder sehr aggressiv
manche können nach außen gut
funktionieren sind dann aber im Zelt
sehr introvertiert und verhalten sich
nicht mehr altersgerecht und Messen zum
Beispiel das Bett ein
4000 Menschen leben in nurda in Zelten
und Containern der staatliche
Katastrophenschutz hat ein vorzeigecamp
errichtet mit einer Schule einem
Kindergarten und Spielplätzen fast zwei
Millionen Menschen sind in der Türkei
obdachlos geworden darunter
hunderttausende Kinder der 17-Jährige
batoren hat viele aus seiner Familie und
auch Freunde verloren er weiß nicht wie
es weitergehen soll
im ersten Jahr am Gymnasium kam Corona
auch im zweiten Jahr jetzt das Erdbeben
ich hatte bisher gar kein richtiges
Leben auf dem Gymnasium
Normalität wird es für die Kinder hier
wohl lange nicht geben aber vielleicht
so etwas wie Alltag es war nur
jedenfalls freut sich darüber dass sie
im Camp immerhin wieder zur Schule gehen
kann
einmal im Jahr kommt in Peking der
Nationale Volkskongress zusammen aber
morgen ist es wieder soweit offiziell
ist es Chinas Parlament aber die fast
3000 Delegierten sind weitgehend
machtlos und winken die Politik durch es
soll eine neue Regierung willigt werden
sie den Ping für eine dritte Amtszeit
als Staatschef bestätigt werden und es
geht um die Wirtschaft das Wachstumsziel
wo rund fünf Prozent für dieses Jahr
Elisabeth mit berichtet
viele Bars und Restaurants mussten
schließen in dieser beliebten
Ausgehmeile in Shanghai erst die strenge
nullcovic-politik dann die abrupten
Öffnungen und mit ihnen eine massive
corona-infektionswelle die Folgen sind
auch in Chinas Wirtschaftsmetropole
sichtbar
früher war hier immer viel los Corona
hat die Leute hart getroffen die
Konsumlaune im Land ist noch schwach die
Immobilienbranche in einer Krise und am
Shanghaier Hafen dem größten der
weltstapeln sich leere Container 80%
weniger Umschlag als vor einem Jahr
einige ausländische Unternehmen Sony und
Apple etwa haben bereits große Teile
ihrer Produktion in andere asiatische
Länder verlegt dieses deutsche
Unternehmen will weiter in China
produzieren hofft aber auf Reformen das
was China eigentlich früher ausgemacht
hat diese
Vorhersehbarkeit Verlässlichkeit und
auch Effizienz das ist im Moment einfach
nicht gegeben und die Regierung sollte
wirklich alles daran setzen das wieder
herzustellen um eben das Vertrauen von
Konsumenten aber auch Investoren zurück
zu gewinnen Ideologie darf nicht im
Vordergrund stehen zwischen fünf und
sechs Prozent Wirtschaftswachstum wird
die Regierung wohl als Ziel für dieses
Jahr beim Nationalen Volkskongress
herausgeben es wäre doppelt so viel wie
im vergangenen Jahr
in diesem Jahr steht die Staatsregierung
unter großem Druck zu liefern denn sie
hat viel Vertrauen durch die strengen
antikowit-maßnahmen verspielt bei
Unternehmen speziell auch aus dem
Ausland
Chinas Wirtschaft wieder auf Kurs zu
bringen daran wird die Staatsführung in
diesem Jahr gemessen werden
mit Empörung hat Bundestagspräsidentin
Bärbel Bars auf einer Aktion der
klimaschutzgruppe letzte Generation
reagiert ihr viele jedes Verständnis
wenn ein Kunstwerk zum Grundgesetz
beschmiert werde die Aktivistinnen und
Aktivisten hatten in Berlin die
glaskulptur Grundgesetz 49 mit einer
dunklen Flüssigkeit übergossen sie
werfen der Bundesregierung vor sie
heilte am Erdöl fest und tue so zu wenig
gegen den Klimawandel langfristig
gefährdet dass die Grundrechte aller
drei Viertel der Erdoberfläche sind von
Ozean bedeckt gleich zwei Konferenzen
haben sich jetzt mit dem Schutz der
Meere beschäftigt in Panama sagten die
Teilnehmer Staaten fast 20 Milliarden
Dollar zu versprachen Investitionen für
Meeresschutzgebiete nachhaltige
Fischerei und mehr Forschung fast noch
wichtiger bei der UNO gab es harte
Verhandlungen über den Schutz der
Hochsee also die Gebiete die keinem Land
gehören und oft rücksichtslos
ausgebeutet werden kein Niklas berichtet
Finnwale in der Tiefsee orientierungslos
oder gar in ihrem Lebensraum bedroht
nicht nur Plastikmüll auch Öl und
Gasförderung oder der Abbau von
Edelmetallen gefährden das Ökosystem
unverhandlungen in New York zum Schutz
der Artenvielfalt auf hoher See sind nun
auf der Zielgeraden
das ist ein ganz ganz wichtiger Schritt
wir werden erstmals überhaupt in der
Lage sein Meeresschutzgebiete in diesen
Zonen einzurichten wo eigentlich gar
keinen Land die Hoheit hat und wir
werden das sogar auf eine Art und Weise
tun dass wir andere schon bereits
bestehende Institutionen für Fischerei
für Schifffahrt und so weiter mit
einbeziehen können so dass wir auch
wirklich Meeresschutzgebiete einrichten
die am Ende auch Zähne haben werden es
geht um Meeresgebiete die mehr als 200
Seemeilen von einer Küste entfernt
liegen und etwa 60% der Meeresoberfläche
ausmachen die Hochsee momentan so
Greenpeace Beute eine Handvoll
überwiegend reicher Nation die hohe See
aus
das wird jetzt die harte Arbeit sein
dafür zu sorgen dass es auch ein
wirklich effektiven Schutz dieser
Gebiete gibt das bedeutet für uns eben
frei von Fischerei frei von anderen
ausnutzungsformen wie Tiefseebergbau
oder Öl und Gasindustrie in den Tiefen
der Meere Überlebenskünstler angepasst
an einen Kagen Lebensraum mit eigenen
Lichtquellen Tiefsee Tiere die
Erkenntnisse auf das gesunde alt werden
oder gegen Krebs in sich tragen wie
können wir diese möglichen Erkenntnisse
die jetzt erst beginnen in der Zukunft
aber riesige Werte darstellen wie können
wir die gemeinsam als
Staatengemeinschaft regeln wenn
gleichzeitig das Leben in den Meeren
bedroht ist das genau ist nun die
Aufgabe die die Vereinten Nationen mit
der Vereinbarung zum Schutz der
Artenvielfalt lösen müssen
bei den Nordischen Ski
Weltmeisterschaften gab es die letzte
Entscheidung im Skispringen aber ja
leider ohne Medaille für Deutschland
sind nur Katharina Althaus geschafft im
Teamwettbewerb der Männer heute also
triumphieren die Gastgeber Slowenien
gewinnt in Planitzer vor Norwegen und
Österreich Deutschland auf Platz 5
die Wartezeit ist kurz Sloweniens
Mannschaft gewinnt mit schlusspringer
angelanischek und deutlich im Vorsprung
die heimischen Fans freuen sich über den
zweiten Titel nach Gold im Einzel
springen gestern zuvor übernimmt
Norwegen die Führung Halver
grande 135,5 Meter aber Norwegen muss
10,5 Punkte auf die Slowenien aufholen
dann springt Angela nischek gleiche
Weite und die reicht zum klaren Sieg
seiner Mannschaft
Titelverteidiger Deutschland nur Fünfter
Markus eisenbichler auf Anraten des
Teamchefs mit verkürztem Anlauf und
Bonuspunkte gut zu machen aber der
deutsche verfehlt die angepeilte weite
um knapp einen halben Meter der Jubel
etwas verfrüht
Österreichs Team sichert sich mit Stefan
Kraft als letzten Springer Bronze
[Applaus]
in der Fußball-Bundesliga hat der FC
Schalke 04 nach fast 16 Wochen den
letzten Platz im direkten Duell wieder
an den VfL Bochum abgegeben die Schalker
gewinnen auswärts 2:0 und feiern den
zweiten Sieg nacheinander Augsburg
schlägt Werder Bremen 2:1 Hoffenheim
ohne Sieg seit Mitte Oktober 0:1 in
Mainz keine Tore bei Union Berlin gegen
Köln und Mönchengladbach gegen den SC
Freiburg am Abend Stuttgart gegen Bayern
München gestern Dortmund gegen Leipzig
2:12 Spiele morgen Bayern München muss
in Stuttgart gewinnen um die
Tabellenführung von Dortmund
zurückzuholen dahinter Union Leipzig
Freiburg unverändert Mainz mit dem
vierten Sieg nacheinander zumindest
vorläufig auf Platz 7 in der zweiten
Tabellenhälfte hinter Augsburg eine 5er
Blockbildung wobei Hertha und Stuttgart
noch punkten können das Trio Hoffenheim
Schalke Bochum am Schluss auf jeden Fall
punktgleich
der VfB gegen die Bayern ausführlich im
Aktuellen Sportstudio um 23 Uhr zu Gast
ist Abwehrspieler Robin Knoche von Union
Berlin
Weltmeister Max Verstappen geht morgen
zum Auftakt der Formel 1 Saison direkt
wieder von der Pole Position ins Rennen
auf dem Kurs in Bahrain ist der
Niederländer gut 0,7 Sekunden schneller
als Charlie Claire im vergangenen Jahr
der wird heute Dritter hinter
verstappenste teamkolleges Nico
Hülkenberg im Harz erreicht überraschend
die dritte Qualifikationsrunde und wird
aus Reihe 5 starten
und das war's Dankeschön Norbert einmal
im Weltraum schweben und auf die Erde
schauen fällt ist das ja auch von ihnen
Traum sie zumindest aus einer anderen
Perspektive betrachten jetzt möglich in
der Dresdner Frauenkirche unser blauer
Planet wenn auch millionenfach kleiner
als das Original
maßstabsgetreu zusammengesetzt aus
hunderten Satellitenaufnahmen eine
schwebende Kunstinstallation die zeigen
soll wie zerbrechlich unsere Erde ist zu
sehen noch bis Ende März
grau mit etwas Regen und Schnee der
Sonntag bringt nur wenig Sonne mehr auch
zum Wetter nächste Woche gleich von
Katja horneffer das heute journal läuft
an diesem Abend um 22:45 Uhr mit
Marietta Slomka tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend das wird ein trüber Sonntag
und damit Sie wissen was am Montag auf
sie zukommt lassen wir diesen Film mal
bis Montagabend laufen da kommt nämlich
tief Björn heran und bringt Schneeregen
und Schnee mit den gibt es allerdings
auch schon in dieser Nacht der Schnee
fällt hier im Osten im Westen ist eher
Schnee Regen zum Teil es ist auch mal
klar wie in Schleswig-Holstein oder auch
am Oberrhein dort bildet sich dann Nebel
die Temperaturen sinken auf zwei Grad am
Niederrhein oder auch auf die
ostfriesischen Inseln und bis minus vier
Grad am Alpen Rand und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen in den Mittelgebirgen
um 1 Grad am Alpenrand um zwei Grad
sonst sind es so drei bis sieben Grad
mit dem mildesten Werten hier am Main
oder auch am Niederrhein und das wird
ein drüber Sonntag morgen gibt's ein
paar mehr Schneeflocken etwas mehr
Schneeregen als noch heute und meistens
ist es eben trüb Sonne sehen Sie
vielleicht mal an der Ostsee auch in
Schleswig-Holstein und vom Oberrhein bis
ins All und am Montag kommen dann neue
Schneeregen Wolken von Nordwesten heran
am Dienstag reicht es vielleicht sogar
für Wintergewitter im Norden und das bei
Temperaturen an den nächsten drei Tagen
von 0 bis 9 Grad das ist März Winter
schönes Wochenende